y tú tienes un corazón en tu pecho y
este corazón básicamente lo que es es
una bomba muscular que se la pasa todo
el tiempo bombeando sangre a todo tu
cuerpo no crea en la sangre entra al
corazón y es bombeada al resto del
cuerpo aunque el corazón necesita
bombear sangre a todo el cuerpo y de
hecho trabaja muchísimo bombea sangre
aproximadamente 100 mil veces al día y
no es que yo esté inventando este número
en verdad bombea 100 mil veces al día
y este número lo podemos calcular
tomando el ritmo cardíaco promedio que
es de aproximadamente 72 latidos por
minuto y multiplicando lo por la
cantidad de minutos que hay en un día
eso es aproximadamente 103 mil veces al
día eso es muchísimo no corazón
realmente es un músculo que trabaja
muchísimo ahora los órganos que trabajan
muchísimo no necesitan algo pues puedes
ponerte a pensar en la última vez que
saliste a correr o la última vez que
escalas de una barda o hiciste una
maroma o cualquier cosa que tú hagas que
muevan mucho tus músculos los músculos
necesitan mucho oxígeno cierto tú más o
menos que sentiste la última vez que
hiciste mucho ejercicio
seguramente sentías que estaba
respirando mucho no no sentías que
tenías una respiración un poco agitada
por lo menos estaba respirando más que
normalmente no y la razón por la que
esto sucede cuando uno hace ejercicio es
porque estás usando tus músculos los
cansaste un poco y usaron todo el
oxígeno que tenían a la mano y ahora les
tienes que dar un poco más de oxígeno y
bueno pues
corazón realmente no es diferente
podríamos llegar a pensar que oye tu
corazón tiene acceso a toda esta sangre
que está bombeando hacia el resto del
cuerpo
cierto no puedes simplemente tomar
oxígeno a partir de toda esa sangre que
está bombeando al cuerpo pero resulta
que no ok para que quede más claro
déjame dibujo por aquí un corte por aquí
vamos a poner el corte del corazón y
como puedes ver en este corte las
paredes del corazón son bastante gruesas
entonces el oxígeno en la sangre que
está fluyendo adentro del corazón no
puede llegar a todas las células de la
pared del corazón ok porque tiene unas
paredes bastante gruesas puede ser que
aporte un poco de oxígeno en la sección
interior de las paredes del corazón pero
la sangre con el oxígeno no va a poder
penetrar suficientemente adentro de la
pared del corazón porque es una pared
bastante gruesa
sin embargo tenemos una solución a este
problema y se llaman arterias coronarias
y las tenemos por aquí ok
esta es la arteria coronaria derecha que
como podemos ver son arterias que están
por afuera del corazón y por aquí
tenemos la arteria coronaria izquierda
bueno más bien la arteria descendente
anterior izquierda que es una rama de la
arteria coronaria izquierda así es que
otra vez estas arterias coronarias son
la solución porque le llevan una muy
buena cantidad de sangre oxigenada al
músculo del corazón de esta forma le
alimentan suficiente oxígeno para que
pueda hacer todo el trabajo que tiene
que hacer pero por supuesto las arterias
coronarias también se pueden enfermar
y la enfermedad de la arteria coronaria
o también conocida como cardiopatía
isquémica es sólo una de las muchas
cosas que pueden salir mal con los vasos
coronarios tal vez hayas escuchado el
término arterias obstruidas como una
forma para describir esta enfermedad y
la razón por la que la describen de esta
forma es porque en efecto hay algunas
sustancias grasosas que se aglomeran y
es prácticamente como cuando se tapan
las tuberías entonces vamos a dibujarlo
por aquí vamos a poner un acercamiento
del vaso coronario porque ahí tenemos
una pared por aquí y otra pared por acá
y por aquí está toda la sangre aquí
y también vamos a poner algunos
componentes de la sangre por aquí hay
unos glóbulos rojos y luego también hay
glóbulos blancos pero pues también
tenemos colesterol y bueno en algún
momento cuando el colesterol está
fluyendo por tu sangre puede ser que se
encuentre con una pared de un vaso
sanguíneo un poco dañado y cuando el
colesterol se encuentra un pedazo de
arteria de este estilo piensa oye este
es un excelente lugar para quedarme por
aquí así es que el colesterol se va a
depositar en el interior de las paredes
de los vasos sanguíneos dañada y en ese
momento van a llegar los glóbulos
blancos a los que no les gusta nada que
el colesterol se esté quedando adentro
de la pared del vaso sanguíneo y estos
glóbulos blancos van a tratar de sacar
el colesterol de la pared pero pues al
hacer esto empieza un proceso
inflamatorio conocido como
arterioesclerosis y bueno esto
simplemente significa endurece
del vaso sanguíneo porque el proceso a
lo largo del tiempo hace que el vaso
sanguíneo se convierta cada vez más duro
y menos flexible y desafortunadamente
durante este proceso mueren un montón de
glóbulos blancos y entonces el
colesterol puede seguirse depositando en
ese lugar y todo ese colesterol junto
con los glóbulos blancos muertos crean
un bulto estorboso al que le llamamos la
placa y con el tiempo la placa se vuelve
cada vez más estorbosa ahora porque es
esto un problema pues es un problema
porque la sangre tiene que pasar por las
arterias y esta placa se vuelve cada vez
más estorbosa si tienes este estorbo
allí en medio de la arteria entonces a
la sangre le va a costar más trabajo
pasar por la arteria aunque bueno al
principio la sangre no va a tener ningún
problema pasando por este espacio más
estrecho sobre todo porque al principio
la placa es mucho más flaca
se necesitan décadas para que esta placa
se vuelva lo suficientemente estorbosa
como para que se vuelva relevante
clínicamente eso quiere decir
simplemente que se tarda décadas en que
empiezas a notar los primeros síntomas
de la formación de esta placa así es que
con el tiempo se va a volver cada vez
más estorbos a la placa y después con el
tiempo vas a empezar a tener algunos
problemas y ahora sólo para dejarlo muy
claro voy a repetir un poco la
cardiopatía isquémica también conocida
como la enfermedad de las arterias
coronarias es cuando en las arterias
coronarias se empieza a formar esta
placa claro que ahora necesitamos un
poco más de espacio entonces voy a
borrar todo esto y la razón por la que
la cardiopatía isquémica es mala por la
que la acumulación de esta placa es mala
es porque puede provocar otras
enfermedades del corazón un poco más
problemáticas
si es que simplemente vamos a describir
las principales vamos a empezar por una
que tal vez ya hayas escuchado antes que
es la angina de pecho estable vamos a
empezar poniendo atención a este pedazo
de músculo de corazón al cual la arteria
está mandando sangre oxigenada y digamos
por ejemplo que nuestra placa está por
aquí
cuando estás descansando cuando tu
corazón no está siendo demasiado
ejercicio y por lo tanto no necesita
demasiado oxígeno la sangre que fluye a
lo largo de esta arteria es suficiente
sangre como para oxigenar a este pedazo
del corazón que entonces está llegando
suficiente sangre con suficiente oxígeno
y este pedazo del corazón está contento
ok no está sufriendo ninguna
consecuencia
entonces en descanso todo está perfecto
qué pasa cuando se va a ir el camión y
tienes que correr para alcanzarlo y qué
pasa si realmente quieres impresionar a
esta otra persona y entonces te metes a
clases de danza o al gimnasio pues
cuando le pides a tu corazón que haga
más trabajo tu corazón va a latir más
rápido y bueno cuando le pides a tu
corazón que haga más trabajo pues tu
ritmo cardíaco sube tienes más latidos
por minuto este músculo del corazón está
haciendo más ejercicio y entonces
necesitan más oxígeno pero por esta
arteria obstruida no puede pasar mucha
sangre y de repente la cantidad de
sangre que está llegando al corazón no
va a ser suficiente no está pasando
suficiente sangre y entonces este pedazo
del corazón se vuelve tóxico porque no
le está llegando suficiente oxígeno al
crear y entonces cuando el ritmo
cardíaco sube se presenta un síntoma al
que llamamos angina de pecho ahora
la palabra encina viene del latín y
significa estrangular entonces la encina
del pecho es esta sensación de
estrangulamiento en el pecho muy
dolorosa que aparece cuando el músculo
de tu corazón no tiene suficiente
oxígeno ahora esto es reproducible ok si
reduces el esfuerzo si dejas de hacer
ese paso de danza exótico o si dejas de
correr para alcanzar el autobús si dejas
de hacer todo eso y respiras muy bien
básicamente le estás pidiendo a tu
corazón que haga menos esfuerzo cierto y
cuando tu corazón hace menos trabajo
necesita menos oxígeno y de repente la
sangre que todavía puede pasar a un lado
de la placa lleva suficiente oxígeno
para satisfacer las necesidades del
corazón pero eso es sólo porque el
corazón ya no está haciendo tanto
esfuerzo así es que con un poco de
reposo los síntomas de la angina
desaparecen el dolor desaparece porque
el corazón está
teniendo suficiente oxígeno ahora la
razón por la que esto se llama angina de
pecho estable es porque tú puedes
predecir los síntomas lo que tú puedes
provocar el dolor de pecho tú puedes
provocar la angina de pecho al pedirle
al corazón que haga más esfuerzo y
también puedes hacer que desaparezca el
dolor haciendo que el corazón descanse y
el esfuerzo va a provocar dolor pero si
reduces el esfuerzo desaparece el dolor
ahora las cosas se pueden poner un poco
más complicadas y cuando se ponen más
complicadas vienen toda una serie de
condiciones y enfermedades a las que
llamamos síndrome coronario agudo y el
síndrome coronario agudo se puede
subdividir en por ejemplo en mi cine
inestable que me imagino que ya tienes
una idea más o menos de qué se trata
porque aquí tenemos la angina estable
y en infarto y el síndrome coronario
agudo se divide en imagina inestable y
en infarto
ahora la angina de pecho estable no es
un infarto la angina inestable no es un
infarto pero un infarto si es un infarto
pero vamos a ver la angina inestable
primero antes de llegar al infarto ahora
para ver la angina inestable tenemos que
recordar nuestra placa ok estoy aquí es
la arteria y esto de aquí es la placa
toda esta cosa de aquí que nuestra nada
bonita es nuestra placa ahora algunas
veces ya sea por pura hipertensión por
poner estrés en esta placa o por alguna
cuestión espontánea que suceda en el
momento bueno de hecho hay otro par de
razones por las que esto podría pasar
pero esas dos razones son las
principales razones por las que esto
sucede en algunas ocasiones esta placa
de colesterol
ahora cuando se rompe un pedazo de una
placa o por ejemplo cuando explota la
cubierta de la placa entonces toda esta
mugre toda esta grasa con células
muertas desagradable se queda expuesta
en la sangre y la placa expuesta en la
sangre de esta forma es muy trombo
génica ya qué me refiero yo con trombo
génica pues me refiero a que provoca que
se formen coágulos de sangre a su
alrededor ahora cuando la sangre se
encuentre con este material que se salió
de la placa que es grasas y colesterol y
células muertas y todo la sangre se va a
volver loca
ok porque en la sangre también tenemos
todas nuestras plaquetas y todos
nuestros factores de coagulación
entonces se va a formar una masa
alrededor de todas las moléculas que
salieron de nuestra placa y entonces se
está empezando a formar un coágulo lo
que hay un coágulo de sangre alrededor
de nuestra placa rota
a partir de ese momento hay dos cosas
que pueden suceder este pedazo de placa
roto podría empezar a moverse hacia la
derecha ya la izquierda porque la placa
está rota de esta parte pero puede ser
que no esté completamente rota de este
otro lado y esto significa que algunas
veces tu arteria va a estar
completamente bloqueada pero otras veces
la placa va a regresar a donde estaba la
placa va a estar pegada contra la pared
dejando pasar la sangre y entonces la
placa va a estar oscilando entre
quedarse pegada a la pared y estar
bloqueando la arteria ahora recuerda lo
que estábamos diciendo antes si no le
permitimos a los músculos del corazón
tener suficiente oxígeno las células
empiezan a sufrir de hipoxia y empiezan
los dolores de pecho lo que ahí empieza
la angina pero ahora tenemos esta placa
que está oscilando así es que en
cualquier segundo puedes perder el flujo
de sangre hacia las células de los
músculos
en cualquier segundo puedes perder tu
suplemento de oxígeno temporalmente así
es que en esta condición en la angina
inestable puedes tener dolor de pecho
incluso cuando estés en reposo no
necesitas hacer un esfuerzo para obtener
los dolores de pecho y esto es porque la
placa está oscilando por aquí el dolor
puede suceder en cualquier segundo y por
eso le llamamos inestable a la angina
inestable porque no es predecible y
puede suceder en cualquier momento ahora
lo último que nos falta hablar acerca
del síndrome coronario agudo es el
infarto
ahora recuerdas que dijimos que la placa
se rompe y un montón del interior de
esta placa ahora está en contacto con la
sangre y los factores de coagulación
empiezan a aglomerarse a su alrededor
bueno pues los glóbulos rojos también
pueden llegar y unirse a esta fiesta
ahora pueden suceder una de dos cosas o
el coágulo que por cierto también se
puede llamar tromba el coágulo se puede
volver tan grande que bloquea toda la
arteria a lo cual les llamamos trombosis
la otra cosa que puede suceder es que el
trombo en lugar de crecer y bloquear por
completo a la arteria un pedazo del
trombo se separe y cuando esto sucede
cuando un pedazo del trombo se separa se
llama embolización entonces un trombo se
puede embolsar y viajar con la sangre
corriente de abajo
una vena un poco más angosta así es que
tenemos aquí un ejemplo de como un
trombo se puede embolsar y bloquear una
arteria un poco más pequeña y ahora
cuando alguna de estas dos opciones
sucede entonces ahora sí podemos decir
que tenemos un ataque al corazón aunque
hay que tenemos un infarto esto ya no se
va a resolver por sí mismo y estos
coágulos están bloqueando por completo
el acceso a oxígeno a ciertas células
del corazón ok ahora hay una parte del
corazón a la cual ya no le está llegando
el oxígeno y entonces las células de esa
parte del corazón a las cuales les
llegaba oxígeno a partir de esa arteria
que está bloqueada
todas estas células de aquí como no
están obteniendo oxígeno se van a morir
porque hay estas células por falta de
oxígeno se van a morir y bueno si llegas
al hospital y te hacen una intervención
quirúrgica
en menos de 20 minutos entonces todavía
puede llegar a salvar este pedazo de
corazón si ese bloqueo de sangre sucede
por un coágulo que bloquea por completo
la arteria o si es un bloqueo de sangre
a un vaso sanguíneo más chico más
cercano a las células provocado por la
embolización de este trombo si sucede en
cualquiera de esas dos cosas y
mantenemos a estas células sin oxígeno
por más de 20 minutos entonces estas
células están permanentemente muertas y
eso es lo que es un infarto que hay un
ataque al corazón ahora otra cosa en la
que lleva a hacer hincapié es que el
infarto no es lo mismo que la
insuficiencia cardíaca
la insuficiencia cardíaca es cuando tu
corazón no puede bombear suficiente
sangre aunque al menos no lo que tu
cuerpo necesita
eso es la insuficiencia cardiaca pero el
infarto es completamente diferente acá y
el infarto sucede cuando una parte de tu
corazón muere porque hay una parte del
corazón del músculo del corazón se muere
porque no está obteniendo suficiente
oxígeno ok
esa es la diferencia entre un infarto y
la insuficiencia cardíaca son dos cosas
completamente distintas pero cada una
puede provocar que la otra suceda